one place we won't hear any mention of
Ryan Lochte is at the Emmys host Jimmy
Kimmel told a new Chanel Turner that
Ryan will not be the butt of a joke and
he gave us even more surprising details
about his monologue Tom Hiddleston was
announced as a presenter so are the
Taylor Swift jokes on deck are they
ready you got warm not real I don't know
I just I think it's a little bit weird
to own somebody goes through a breakup
and then suddenly they're on camera and
everyone's making fun of them it's it's
a strange thing it's one of the
strangest things about Hollywood there
are a few that you maybe be a little bit
worried but for the most part everyone
can relax inside Microsoft theater we
checked out where all the stars are
gonna be seated and just out of the
hospital for food poisoning Amy Schumer
has a seat up front and the Modern
Family cast is grouped together and then
guess who I spotted right across the
aisle here in the second row oh yeah
Queen B Beyonce in the house
I'm with pretty close proximity to the
stage I might add never know
Jimmy helped roll out the Emmy red
carpet this morning and looking pretty
good in a tux
his slimmed-down secret is a well we'll
call it a starvation diet that sounds
pretty crazy then I decided all you know
what I'll do I'll stop eating on Monday
and Thursday and we'll see how that goes
do you miss food those days of the week
I spend the whole day online looking at
recipes I mean Jimmy you look great but
not eating two days a week is badness I
would never make it